HOW CAN TEXAS HELP TO SAVE THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY?
WELL TONIGHT WE ARE HAPPY TO
TELL YOU THE GOVERNOR OF THE ST,
HAS MOBILIZED THE TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD TO PROTECT THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF THIS COUNTRY AND
OF HIS STATE.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS,
GREG ABBOTT, JOINS US NOW TO
EXPLAIN WHAT HE IS DOING.
MR. GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
IF YOU DON'T MIND, AND IF YOU
COULD GIVE OUR VIEWERS AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT HAVE YOU YOU
HAVE DONE TO SECURE OUR BORDER H
MEXICO.
>> I WILL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
WE ARE DOING BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE A PHRASE YOU USED
EARLIER, THAT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGING THIS, WHICH IS IN
CONTRAST TO WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS TAKEN OVER, WHAT TEXAS HAS
DONE, WE NOW HAVE 6500
NATIONAL GUARD AND DPS TROOPERS
ON THE BORDER TO HELP SECURE THE
BORDER, AND AS WE ARE TALKING
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE IDENTIFYING
LOCATIONS ON THE BORDER WHERE
THEY ARE LAYING DOWN RAZOR WIRE
TO SECURE ALL THE POSSIBLE
CROSSINGS THAT THESE CARAVANS
MAY BE COMING TO, AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT, BEGINNING
TODAY, WE BEGIN DROPPING THESE
LARGE CONTAINERS THAT YOU SEE ON
18-WHEELERS, THAT YOU ALSO SEE
ON THESE SHIPS THAT ARE GOING
ACROSS THE OCEAN, WE ARE
DROPPING THEM DOWN ON LOCATIONS
THAT COULD BE CROSSINGS THAT
WOULD BE USED BY THESE CARAVANS
TO SERVE AS A BLOCKADE TO
PREVENT THEM FROM COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT, IF THEY DO COME ACROSS THE
BORDER, THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY ARE AUTHORIZED TO ARREST
ANY OF THESE PEOPLE WHO MAKE IT
THROUGH OUR BLOCKADE EFFORTS AND
PUT THEM IN JAIL FOR VIOLATING A
CRIME OF CRIMINAL TRESPASSING IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS, AND TUCKER,
ON TOP OF THAT, TEXAS IS
STEPPING UP AND WE ARE BUILDING
OUR OWN BORDER WALL.
THAT PROCESS HAS ALREADY BEGUN.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
BIDS ON IT AND I AM TOLD TO
EXPECT PART OF THE TEXAS WALL
TO BE COMPLETED BEFORE THE END
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
WHEN THE COUNTRY FALLS APART,
STATES HAVE TO ACT LIKE
COUNTRIES.
SO YOU ARE THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OF A STATE WHOSE SOVEREIGNTY IS
BEING VIOLATED BY FOREIGN
NATIONALS.
MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT EVEN FROM
NEARBY COUNTRIES, OR
LATIN AMERICA, BUT AROUND THE
WORLD.
IT SEEMS YOU ARE DOING THE
SENSIBLE THING, THE ONLY THING.
WHAT KIND OF PUSHBACK DO YOU
EXPECT TO GET FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR DOING THIS?
>> LISTEN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN PUSHING
BACK EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THAT I DID,
TUCKER, I ISSUED AN ORDER OF
PREVENTING ANY OF THE NGOs OR
OTHER ASSISTED AIDES IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS FROM TRANSPORTING
OR MOVING ANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
WITHIN THE STATE OF TEXAS
BECAUSE OF HEALTH CARE REASONS,
BECAUSE OF POSSIBLE SPREAD OF
COVID.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SUED
ME, THEY WENT TO FEDERAL COURT,
THEY GOT A FEDERAL COURT TO RULE
THAT MY EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I WILL CONTINUE TO ACT, HOWEVER,
BUT IT JUST GOES TO SHOW THE
LEVEL OF PUSHBACK BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, EVEN TRYING TO
DENY ME TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF MY FELLOW TEXANS.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE HAD
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COME FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES MOVING THROUGH
TEXAS, AND THEN COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW -- TO WHAT DEGREE CAN YOU
STANCH THE FLOW OF PEOPLE COMING
IN ILLEGALLY, DO YOU THINK?
>> SO, THE BEST WAY WE CAN DO
THAT IS THE STRATEGIES THAT WE
ARE EMPLOYING AS WE SPEAK RIGHT
NOW, AND THAT IS TO IDENTIFY ALL
OF THESE LOCATIONS WHERE THEY
MAY BE COMING ACROSS, AND THEY
ARE CALLED LOW WATER CROSSING
AREAS, AND THEN TO SERVE AS
BLOCKADES IN THOSE REGIONS SO
THAT WE WILL BE PREVENTING THE
PEOPLE FROM COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
>> Tucker: WHAT -- I HAVE TO
ASK YOU, SINCE YOU DEAL WITH
THIS EVERY DAY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
MOTIVE IS IN THROWING OPEN OUR
BORDERS TO THE WORLD?
>> IT IS CLEAR, KIND OF WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
JOE BIDEN BELIEVES IN OPEN
BORDER POLICIES, AND HIS
MINISTRY CAN DO, AND THEY ARE
TRULY TRYING TO REDESIGN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, IN A
COMPLETE LAWLESS WAY.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THIS ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WENT ALL THE
DEMOCRATS WERE ON THE SAME
DEBATE STAGE TALKING ABOUT,
QUITE LITERALLY, THESE
SOCIALISTIC POLICIES THEY WOULD
EMPLOY IN THE UNITED STATES,
WHICH MIMIC OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
HER ACOLYTES, AND THEY ARE
ACTING OUT ON ALL THOSE POLICIES
AND PROMISES THEY MADE DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
THAT LEAVES IT TO THE STATES NOW
TO STEP UP AND DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HOLD ONTO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA UNTIL
REPUBLICANS CAN REGAIN CONTROL
OF CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Tucker: YEAH, WITH NEW
ATTITUDE